this week's Vegas drives takes us to
Spring Mountain Ranch Las Vegas now's
Julian Lopez shows us the hidden Jam
that's super summer theater and a picnic
dinner theater experience Under the
Stars take a look
[Music]
well today's adventure takes us inside
the beautiful mountains of Spring
Mountain Ranch and we are just about 45
minutes outside of Las Vegas gonna check
out the Super Summer theater it happens
every summer out here but first we have
to unload the car so let's get to it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
things I'm ready to get set up to see
the show but before we do that we are
hanging out with Lisa who has been a
part of Super Summer theater for a while
now and Lisa this is one of my favorite
places I'm excited to share it with
everybody for but for people who haven't
been here how would you describe the
experience out here it's an amazing
experience I've been involved for about
25 years and I remember the first time I
came out here somebody had given me
tickets and I saw a Little Shop of
Horrors and I've been coming out every
year since you don't realize that we're
only about 20 25 minutes out of town but
you feel like you just got transformed
somewhere else and you get out here and
you just go ah Spring Mountain Ranch was
the first working Ranch in Las Vegas and
Still Remains one but has also been
transformed into a theater experience
under the stars I describe it to people
who don't know about this as a picnic
dinner theater
and then I just go from there then I
tell them bring their picnic and then
when the Sun goes down the stage door
goes up and we have our our show that's
right you pack up your picnic or buy
concessions on site purchase Show
tickets online and experience a Super
Summer theater production all these
producers have been waiting two years to
put these amazing shows on so we're very
excited about that each show runs for
about three weeks four nights a week
three different shows a summer with a
lot of prep involved normally it'll take
about say four months from casting to
actually producing the show to actually
what you see right now but there's also
it's probably about a year when you
actually start doing the set design
doing costumes doing uh the music in
your band together so it's a year four
months it's about a Year's worth of
producing also a lot of behind the
scenes work comes solely from gracious
volunteers I don't think people realize
that it's it's a bunch of volunteer
board members providing their time as
well as all of these Volunteers in the
community providing their time and then
those people on the stage who are also
Community performers Superstars both on
and off the stage this is the best kept
secret in southern Nevada
you can catch Vegas drives every
Wednesday right here on Channel 8.